ich mache dieses video weil etwas
anzukündigen geht und zwar ich bin
nächste woche also diese woche ab
donnerstag über meine bei meiner family
und da werde ich ein 3 kaspische machen
und es wird so aussehen
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde
survival games ich hab leider kein skin
dafür jetzt geld nicht mehr gereicht ihr
wisst monatsende dies das unternehmen
ihm ist weiter drüben ist apple hat man
hört man nicht dass bei mir im
hintergrund leute singen schreien ist
fertig
steve noch mal ein extra wissen gar
nichts nein man hat alles schweren einer
du hast richtig aber in ihren mikrofon
alter wieviel alter ich hab einfach mal
zwei euro extra
einstein alle noten sind bei mir
konflikt euch doch geht immer auf dem
youtube klein scheiß ich installiere ich
kann nicht schützen
mach das bitte ich sie lösen kinder
ich habe einfach nicht fertig aber
immerhin ok alte leute als der junge
trägt man den song vorstellen usk zwei
getötete kämpfer getötet
das treffen bei der dinge bei der
familie seiner mutter kind das seine
mutter verlassen
es ist eine szene wie adiga also leute
mit dabei sind vertritt und crafter
kraft da ist dann sollte ich mache
dieses video weiß was anzukündigen geht
es war ich bin nächste woche also diese
woche ab dass jost und da werde ich ein
3 kaspische machen und es wird so
aussehen
wir machen einen livestream pro babbel
lässt finger nicht direkt mit dem bruder
natürlich krankhafter yao alter wird er
mich gefügt
oh oh oh mein penis groß egal
eur o mein gott bitte mir schon nämlich
ich bin nun youtuber ich bin ich nehme
alles rausquetschen hören als der typ
der gerade war gerade richtig bestimmt
67 jetzt mit der axt gegeben ist einfach
nicht gestorben
ach du warst ja der ddr
du bist auch in sevengames läuft alles
nicht mehr ab dabei möchten aber
trotzdem ist leicht trotzdem wette wie
bitte oder danke mit der stein
schwertner
ihr könnt hast du gar keine schuld ich
hab alles mit holz geschickt also dann
das päckchen dabei kürzt zuerst
natürlich noch gut wissen was erzählen
wenn du dazu fähig anzuschauen wir noch
nicht sagt dass sie das t-shirt alter
nein man doch ganz leicht und töne
richtig heftig mikrofon verstellt so
viel zu heftig equipment alter wo es so
vettel er sehe dich bist du der abwehr
ich habe keine hast du also leuten zu
sagen was brauchst du die hälfte ja ich
hab ich hab 08 und ich habe dann auch
für die htg diesem falle also leute ihr
nächstes woche eine menge freiheiten
macht alle termine kenzelmann ersten
leistung machen ich wollte es richtig
drauf weil ich finde leistet livestream
ist immer so ein bisschen noch ein
bisschen persönlicher als als einfach
nur videos weil er auch mentale dinge
passieren und das ist uns ganz ehrlich
ist in die kommentare schreiben
wer gewinnen wird der junge es geht doch
gar nicht loslassen stellen
oder max und schreibt auch in die
kommentare welche spiele bei facebook
patrick ist mit dem feuerzeug muss man
sagen ihr könnt ihr einfach die schwert
hat er sich das ist mega gelehrten
überlassen weil das geht eben in zweifel
es geht nicht immer alles ganz verzückt
ich hätte patrick einfach so oft töten
könnte schon diese rinde ist der grund
dass du über so weit gekommen
ja weil lustige runde ich glaube die
infos sind ganz gut rübergekommen oder
auch nicht auf max richter weil man ja
zu schlecht ist ja und ja dann würde ich
sagen
haut rein macht's gut patrick max in der
beschreibung petridis generation
kammerchors lieder mal vorbeischaut und
max ist die beschreibung ok maxis auch
in der beschreibung
dann checkt